i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight as youtube
kicks users off its platform under the
guise of coveted misinformation
the left and the media cheer as if it's
all long overdue
glenn greenwell tells us what the
sensorius tendencies are really about
and do you remember when being a
maverick in the senate mattered well now
that the mag bricks reside on the left
the media is lashing out senator josh
hawley responds to that
but first how to crater the u.s economy
that's the focus of tonight's angle
today is national manufacturing day did
you know that and the white house issued
a proclamation marking the occasion and
it mentions correctly
that american manufacturing is essential
to our economy it employs over 12
million americans directly and many more
indirectly
and it noted how many manufacturing jobs
were upended during the pandemic 578
000. the proclamation also points out
that these losses and other factors
adversely affected our supply chains
supply chain just disruptions left our
nation short of life-saving protective
equipment ventilators and other
essential health equipment at a time
when we needed it most
well there's the rub
when we import so much of what we need
and use from steel to pharmaceuticals
plastics computer chips
we leave ourselves susceptible to huge
economic headwinds and during covid it
ended up being a matter of life and
death
now biden talks a good game about
helping rebuild our supply chains and
supporting american jobs and
manufacturing
but his policies are having the opposite
effect
have you tried buying a refrigerator
lately a car anything with a chip in it
even simple parts for something like a
broken lawnmower or snowblower
imagine what the companies manufacturing
these goods are going through
take a look at the situation at the port
of los angeles
dozens of tankers loaded half a million
containers worth of goods and materials
are just sitting off the coast waiting
to be unloaded
well this is what it looks like when a
labor shortage meets massive under
investment
in infrastructure we've got a lot of
people sitting on the sidelines out
there too
now they simply can't keep up with the
demand you know if you're manufacturing
something you need the parts you need
the elements of it so then what happens
well orders are slowed dramatically some
orders are canceled altogether and then
profits end up plunging
employees are laid off or their benefits
are cut
productivity is hampered and then
economic growth that's eventually hurt
so everybody knows what's happening but
few are willing to talk about how we got
into this supply chain hole and how we
can dig ourselves out of it
the hollowing out over decades of our
manufacturing and industrial base is one
of the main drivers of the problem
businesses following washington's
relaxed trade policies before trump
offshored their operations to maximize
profits by paying lower wages for labor
that's what they were able to do
overseas
now democrats and globalist republicans
alike cheer this as a win-win for
american companies and consumers who get
cheaper stuff
in fact conservatives scoffed at those
of us who warned about destroying
blue-collar jobs
this column written just four years ago
in national review by kevin williamson
is a prime example
he wrote one of the great enduring
stupidities of modern economic life is
the belief that buying american is
somehow beneficial to the united states
as a whole
does buy american create or protect
american jobs
almost certainly not
now it's difficult to imagine a more
misguided view of things but there you
have it
so being reliant on communist china
for anything critical to our survival
is moronic in the short and long term
and most americans are now coming to
understand this fact
now biden didn't create this supply
chain problem but his policy sure won't
fix it
watching democrats today twist
themselves into knots over their
multi-trillion dollar spending bills how
many trillions here how many trillions
there what can we agree to
well we see how clueless they are about
all of this
the reconciliation bill is about the
priorities that are getting funded we
obviously want child care that is
universal we have a
generational obligation a historic
obligation
to address climate change to transition
from fossil fuel combustion to clean and
renewable energy the reconciliation bill
was a culmination of my
service in congress because it was about
the children the children the children
the children
they have no idea how wealth is created
in fact the children know more than they
do
how to build a strong middle class how
to get people back to work how to get
people to want to work again
they don't even think about what things
like this mean why texas is doing better
than new york does nancy ever think
about that
why florida is outpacing illinois
how about why businesses are leaving
states like massachusetts for tennessee
that's what gun manufacturers smith and
wesson just announced they were doing
do the democrats even care
it doesn't seem so they think money
grows on trees
their answer to everything is to borrow
and print more money raise taxes and
regulate industries into the dust
we had a booming economy less than two
years ago we had record low unemployment
we had no inflation and china was back
on its heels
but none of those good outcomes brought
us closer to the progressive political
goals of discrediting capitalism
demonizing wealth creators and
encouraging americans to become ever
more dependent on the government
biden had some decent instincts on the
value of made in america when he visited
that mack trucks plant in pennsylvania
in recent years
buy america has become a hollow promise
but my makes my administration going to
make buy american a reality will be
expanding my made in america initiative
to help cities towns and tribes
get a better deal
when they buy a made in america product
but his administration is being hijacked
by the same globalist forces that dug
the hole that we're in now
he's turning our china policy over to
john kerry essentially that was a very
bad omen
kerry's just a foolish globalist married
to a billionaire invested heavily in
china
meanwhile biden's war on oil and gas is
going to hurt any effort to bring back
manufacturing to the united states
to do that to bring manufacturing back
we need a dependable energy sector that
absolutely must include traditional
sources
unilateral disarmament on energy that's
what those senators were talking about
that's what carrie wants
that's only going to strengthen china's
hand
be a drag in our economy
and we know the ccp will do whatever it
takes to keep their factories running no
matter what
as the wall street journal notes permits
issued by the interior department for
drilling on federal land declined to 171
in august from 671 in april
that's a 75 percent drop in permits
and liberal states are also walking the
progressive plank just this week the
companies behind the 116 mile penn east
pipeline plan that would have brought
crucial natural gas supplies to new
jersey called it quits
why
well legal battles with environmental
radicals that's why and of course the
state of new jersey
the cumulative effect of the left's
energy policies has been to destroy the
energy independence we achieved under
president trump
and then force american families and
small businesses
to maddening levels of price inflation
at the pump
the national average price for gallon
gas is a seven year high right now the
price is an entire dollar higher than
just last year
the price of natural gas is double what
it was last year
so heating bills could be 30 percent
higher this winter
now if that fact alone doesn't wake up
the voters of new england
who have sent nine democrats plus lefty
independents like bernie sanders and
angus king to the u.s senate i don't
know what will
here's the bottom line
everything the democrat democrats are
doing is discouraging investment and job
creation in the united states and at the
same time it's going to encourage it's
going to prompt inflation
we need to end the attacks on our energy
sector fully reopen the economy without
these mandates stop the crippling taxes
and regulations that push businesses
overseas
and stay out of disastrous trade packs
like the trans-pacific partnership
if we keep going down the path
we'll end up with a combination of
unnecessary high unemployment and rising
prices
just like we had in the days of jimmy
carter
looking at all of this i can say one
thing elections cannot come soon enough
and that's the angle
all right joining me now hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else